hey you guys movie retrospective time so
what happened with the patreon thing and
maybe one of you guys did this on
purpose i'm not really sure but every
single one of the five movies in there
got one vote each
so i was like you know what i'm gonna
break this tie and i've been wanting to
do this movie forever and it keeps
coming up in the poll and it never wins
and i'm just kind of like god damn it
i'm gonna do
the devil's reign for gray's sake this
movie is from 1975.
this is kind of like
the cult movie to end all cult movies
not only is it about a satanic cult
but
listen to this [ __ ] cast william
[ __ ] shatner yeah the chat the shad's
in it is in it
it's a good movie
ernest borgniz yeah is in it yeah one of
his best roles with a goat head yeah tom
skerritt is in it pre-alien like he was
he'd been in a couple movies i think
prior to this but he's pretty young in
this this guy that played dallas
yeah yeah keenan is in once
eddie albert is in this from green acres
ida lupino is in this uh joan prather or
prather rather i think it's prather
actually she's been on like a ton of
[ __ ] like tv i think she's best known
for like eight is enough but she was on
like the love boat [ __ ] like that yeah
anton lavey is in this and this might be
is this actually john travolta's
first feature film role now i think he
doesn't really have any lines and you
might not recognize him because he has
kind of like makeup on yeah but i mean
his chin is pretty distinctive so like
when you see him at one point
like you'll probably know it's him but
yeah so anton levay was brought in as
like a technical advisor on this movie
and he actually does kind of like a
satanic
ritual at some point during the movie
you could you can see his influence if
you ever read anton's book satanic bible
he describes what a satanic temple
should look like with the
and that's what they have in the movie
so they took his advice it looks
futuristic
i mean it's inside it's inside like an
old looking like a dilapidated looking
like new england style church but then
inside it's like pretty rad i gotta say
future for the late 60s let's say train
was kind of like art deck look at some
other damn aliens kinda it's cool
looking black and silver i really like
all the uh like i really like the
stained glass with the little goat head
in there it's like it's pretty cool the
only thing that they didn't do is that
the women weren't nude
and anton levay's [ __ ] book said that
when they're doing those satanic rituals
that they would do the women were all
nude i don't think they had any clothes
they just had capes and they didn't want
to do that in this movie i guess because
they probably wouldn't get the [ __ ]
pg rating or whatever i don't know
yeah because i'm pretty sure this is
rated pg yeah even though
i don't know man it's just kind of like
okay so i don't i don't know what it is
about this movie
because i will say that
the story of the movie doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense like you kind
of have to
keep up with the [ __ ] because there's
like a lot of like weird plot holes and
stuff
but there's something about the vibe of
this one and honestly for 1975
the special effects in this look great
and i think that might be because it's
the same uh it's the same people that
worked on the original like planet of
the apes movies yeah so i think that's
probably why i like the special effects
there's some good gimmicks in it
it does it's taking place like in a
ghost town
old west ghost town yeah and there's one
part where i'm looking at and i'm going
man this
but where'd they get that old building
and then as is that a set or is that the
real thing and i'm looking at it and i
recognized it
they it must be on universal's lot or
something universal studios or somewhere
it didn't look like it was out in the
desert in california somewhere i think
it's actually new mexico new mexico is
that where it is i think they shot it so
it might be there might be a real
building
it looked authentic but i recognized it
as
the brothel from rising from um
uh what's it uh red sun which is a
western movie that had a samurai and it
had uh uh uh that one dude from torah
torah torah japanese actor ro musafumi i
don't remember his name and um
um
well what's his name charles bronson
it's a real good movie and i recognized
it from there that
that it had been used before in other
movies
yeah it looks like because when i was
seeing it too even though they set
dressed it to look like it was abandoned
i said that looks like an old west
brothel so it must have been used as
that like yep i recognize in many other
movies because it's very familiar i
recognize the hallways the staircase the
layout is going that's the same one from
uh
red sun
yeah
and like i said i'm sure it's well i
mean i saw it but it was so long ago
that i wouldn't have recognized it from
that but i recognized it from like other
movies
so the guy that directed this robert
west he's a british guy uh probably best
known for doing uh he did a version of
wuthering heights back in 1970 he also
did the abominable dr fibes and dr fives
rises again uh he also did revenge of
the stepford wives from 1980 which is
actually like a pretty good uh movie if
you haven't seen i think i'm pretty sure
it was made for tv but not really sure
but he did some other stuff uh as well
now one of the rumors surrounding this
film i think it wasn't anchor bay but it
was um what's that other uh blu-ray
company that always puts it's not aero
it's somebody but they put out a blu-ray
of this
uh recently
and apparently like it looks fantastic
because the cinematography on this like
all the desert shots and everything like
that are actually really nice it's good
flick and like i said the special
effects are really nice too so there's
like a lot of um they got a lot of
interviews with people like behind the
scenes so one of the most
i don't know like one of the most uh
prominent rumors about this movie is
that the director had a nervous
breakdown on the set
but they did interview i guess the guy
is still alive or was when they were
shooting the interview about this movie
and he said no no he's like i didn't
have a nervous breakdown he's like but
it would have been justified if i had
because it was just that much of a
nightmare i guess
um because i guess the two guys that
wrote the screenplay
um and the guy that was the producer
they were just kind of like look we just
want a movie about satanists where
there's like a big finale where
everybody melts
you know so they're just like why that
what does that have to do with saying
this
one people will get into it but they're
like just write us a story like that so
the two screenwriters that wrote it
like i said the screenplay is not super
super coherent and the director was kind
of like this is incoherent and the
screener is no no no it makes complete
and perfect sense maybe if you're high i
don't know but uh he was just kind of
like okay whatever i couldn't understand
and they wouldn't i mean you i've seen
it i've seen the devil's reign probably
like five or six times and i think i
sort of know what's going on
kind of but i'm actually not entirely
sure it doesn't really matter i just
want it doesn't really matter
it doesn't really matter but he's like
whatever [ __ ] it i'm just gonna make the
movie anyway we'll try to like figure
figure this has much cool seeds in it
yeah
and [ __ ] in the chat yeah but if
ornish bergnine carries this movie i
think this is his best role
he's great in this that's yeah he looks
good too usually you know
when you think of ernest borgnine you
kind of think of a portly dude and kind
of friendly big goofy [ __ ] teeth and
goofy smiles he's a sinister
[ __ ] in this one he does a real
good job he's trimmed down he just looks
like evil
they [ __ ] pulled it off looks like an
evil goat man and then he eventually
does turn into an evil goat man yeah so
i guess he's i guess he's kind of like
possessed by satan at that point and i
actually love
the goat makeup like the the prosthetics
and stuff they don't i i think it looks
fantastic like i said it's the same
people that did playing it at the apes
so
you know that it's gonna look good but i
think it looks i think it looks great
and like his wardrobe looks good too
planet of the apes looked good for its
day yeah and now it just gets the job
done but remember i remember when i was
a kid and it's day looking at the planet
apes i was amazed because you know
gremlins hadn't come out yet or anything
you know
but uh yeah i feel like i feel like the
late 70s early 80s was like when special
effects got like really really good yeah
you know what i mean
but uh yeah particularly in with like
puppets and animatronics so they started
taking them seriously and hiring younger
guys that were way into it
yeah which helps yeah which helps next
thing you know you got the damn alien
and the predator and the [ __ ]
gremlins and [ __ ] yeah
yeah but i but i will say that i do love
the goat makeup in this and the melting
effects are great the funny thing about
it is that what i what i said like the
same producer i think his name is sandy
howard he was the same guy that did like
a man called horse and like some other
westerners exactly yeah and uh yeah and
so he was the one he was the one that
said i want a movie about satanist with
everybody melting at the end for
whatever reason i don't know maybe he
just maybe that's his fetish i don't
know i'm not judging but uh on the
poster not on every single poster but on
some iterations of the devil's reign
poster it says on the bottom and i quote
absolutely the most incredible ending of
any motion picture
ever
ever
is what this poster says
does it live up to that no
but it's still pretty good you do get to
see like a whole bunch of people melting
and it's funny because the ending scene
this movie is not long i think it's only
86 minutes maybe it's not it's barely
it's not even 90 minutes action packed
um but the last scene of like all the
satanist melting spoiler alert uh goes
on for easily 10 minutes maybe more
um
but i guess they spent a lot of money on
the melting so they were just kind of
like [ __ ] it we're showing it all we're
showing it all it looks cool though i
have a feeling stephen king saw this
movie because uh
the beginning part of it with chat and
everything kind of reminded me something
out of the book gunslinger
where you have a cowboy type guy
yeah in the old west
talking to kind of like ex-dimensional
demonic type people and he's got
sacred talisman that the demons want
basically it just struck me as like
i think king saw this
because
that kind of saw a lot of horror around
this thing yeah he's seen all of it
because that kind of setting kind of
reminded me of the beginning of the
gunslinger
in the dark i feel like a lot of horror
movies were set
in the desert back in the like i was
watching like another uh review of this
and they said yeah they shot at the
desert because it's free i guess sorry
[Laughter]
yeah it's right outside l.a and it looks
suitably alien because a lot of people
don't live around it yeah a couple hours
drive outside of la and those days they
didn't have big traffic jams you know i
was growing up there
and when i was a kid you know in the
[ __ ] 70s and very early 80s i left
81.
and uh spent all my summers in
mississippi but the rest of the time i
was in
long beach california and uh no man my
dad used to take me out of the mojave
all the time and they didn't have they
had traffic but it wasn't as bad as it
is now from right here and you could
just get in the car and about two hours
later three hours later be out in the
middle of a [ __ ] desert it was fun
drive too big long straight roads
i feel like i feel like deserts are a
good setting for particular types of
horror movies yeah then you can just
drive off the road and find [ __ ]
campsites where people were
down inside those valleys and those
mountains and just park your camper
there and hang out for three or four
days it's pretty good yeah i was having
fun running around shooting lizards with
a bb gun
don't shoot lizards you just shoot them
with a baby girl they didn't do anything
you're a little kid you know
because i wasn't mean
uh but yeah so uh again from the blu-ray
release because i was watching like
another kind of breakdown of all the
extras that were on the blu-ray
and apparently there are some interviews
with some members of the crew like the
you know the script supervisor and like
the producer and other people like that
one of the things that made me laugh was
that somebody on the crew i can't
remember who it was it was maybe one of
those two people
said they remembered working with
william shatner
and saying that william shatner
loved himself
way more than it is like healthy to love
yourself
that sounds about right and i was like
yeah that tracks
also according to another member of the
crew the shot was kind of jealous
because anton levay was getting all the
press for being in this movie instead of
him even though he was kind of like the
star of the movie yeah although i would
argue that ernest borgnite is actually
kind of the star of the movie
because william shatner spoiler alert he
kind of gets like satanized like halfway
through the movie yeah and so he's not
in it as much because he gets turned
into like an eyeless
accolade that actually surprised me
yeah
that he he he actually was defeated
halfway through it
but because he you think he's going to
be the hero he's not though not really
no so that's kind of good if they kind
of go in an unexpected direction yeah
um but yeah like the fact that i carried
the movie he's actually the star of this
movie if you asked me yeah because once
like once
you know you're 20 like 10 20 minutes
into it like ernest borgnet's in pretty
much the whole thing yeah which made me
think that this is probably borgnine's
best role
and i think that he didn't really take
it all that seriously like he was like
um that was something else that somebody
on the crew said that when he like
looked at himself in the mirror like
with the with the whole get up on
because he has like a cool like satanic
robes and [ __ ] like it's red and uh and
maybe with the goat head and stuff he's
looking at this going oh my god they
can't be serious
but he couldn't see it but yeah to his
credit i mean he's a pro and he just
like went in there did i thought he
looked bad i thought he looked really
cool like in that outfit but you know
maybe maybe it was that uh i will note
too that
william shatner uh because he got turned
into like an eyeless uh satanic accolade
or whatever like halfway through and
there's one like really iconic shot
where you see him and he doesn't have
the eyes and everything and if you're
thinking to yourself oh that looks like
michael myers mask from halloween that's
because that's what that was the michael
myers mask from halloween was william
shatner mask that they cut the eyes out
of so if you kind of see
i think that's the thing the william
shatner mask it wasn't from this movie
though was it it wasn't from the devil's
ring i think i think it was from star
trek i think it was from star trek but
they just cut the eyes out but the fact
that he
in this he has like the eyes out with
like with the big socks he looks like he
looks like that mask so that's why
yeah so let's talk about so okay so
here's the thing but here's what happens
in this movie we're gonna try
and sort it out it's kind of complicated
we're going to try to sort this we're
going to try to sort it out all right
and now i will say that the movie it
starts really strangely because it
starts like really like in the middle of
stuff
and you really don't have any idea
what's going on like pretty much they
start with
the chat like coming home
to his house and ida lupino is his mom
and then there's like another old guy
who lives there but that's not the same
age yeah it really does look like
they're kind of i mean she doesn't look
old enough i'm sure she's probably in
her 60s but she doesn't look old enough
to be his mom because i was just kind of
like wait is that his wife or his mom
and then like he called her mother
because they don't really look that
different in age sorry i don't know what
the actual age difference was but they
didn't look that it didn't look that far
apart
so there's so she's in the house and
then there's another old guy there who's
not his dad because his dad
they're like freaking out because
they're like where's dad he went off to
i think redstone is the name of that
ghost town he went off there or whatever
and we don't know where he is and like
there's a storm coming and blah blah and
then they're talking about like some
book and then they're talking about this
guy named corbis and you're just like
what the [ __ ] is going on
so then
the dad shows back up
but they're like hey it's dad but it's
not dad because he has the
the eyeless kind of [ __ ] going on
and then it starts to rain
and he
like completely melts like down into
there i'm just like oh well there goes
dad we're just gonna have to like
i thought like brandon ten old did a uh
did a review of this and he's like well
i guess we're just gonna hose him off
the driveway
or put him in a bucket or something like
that so
okay so they figure out the satanic cult
has got their dad and then their dad
melted
so william shatner gets mad and he's
like okay well they said redstone and
they said corbis so i'm gonna go there
and see what the [ __ ] is going on
because there's a thing where
he goes outside to his truck
and then there's like a voodoo doll of
his mom
on the steering wheel right and he's out
there for like two minutes max then he
goes back in the house and the old guy
who we don't know who the [ __ ] it is is
hanging upside down and he's all bloody
and stuff and his mom has been kidnapped
like so that happened it that had to be
like supernatural i'm guessing because
he just like literally went out to the
truck saw the voodoo doll and then went
back in and then all that shenanigan had
happened and he didn't see anything
happen so there's that
so he's like okay well the satanic cult
have like kidnapped
my mom and they killed my dad or they
still have my dad that wasn't really his
dad because the melted i don't know i
don't know so there's that so he's like
okay well i gotta go figure out what's
going on so he goes and meets
ernest borgnine who looks kind who looks
normal he's just like in regular cowboy
[ __ ]
but
i had thought that they knew who corbis
was because he knew the name
but then when he goes and starts talking
to ernest borgnine he's like well i'm
looking for corbis or i'll only talk to
corbis he's like dude i'm corvus and
he's like oh okay fair enough
and then they decide they're gonna have
a faith-off
right so there's this old church in the
middle of the desert and he's like well
you have to come in there and
he and chad's like i'm going to go in
the same way i you know came out or
whatever the hell
so i guess
they're going to do whatever faith
chat is um he's jewish in real life but
i'm sure it was probably how i think
he's adopted though or something to do
with like christianity or something i
don't know but uh but ernest borgnine
and his acolytes are satanists obviously
so he's like okay we'll come in here and
you know if you
leave the same way and you still have
your faith then i'll give you your mom
back and your dad back or whatever
so he goes in there
and
then there's like they start doing the
satanic ritual and whatnot
and then
like shat starts
reciting prayers and [ __ ] like that but
then like all the other accolades kind
of jump on him then he starts shooting
at him and they're just like guess your
faith wasn't that strong after all blah
blah and then they eventually like
capture him
and start like putting him up on the
altar and he's like
like you know overacting and whatnot and
uh they cut stuff into his thing and
turn him into one of the things so he's
not the star of the movie he's not the
hero
then what happens is they jump very
abruptly
to
a parapsychology lab yeah i guess yeah i
actually like that part yeah i did too
it was just kind of like but like i said
if you're watching the movie you're just
like what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] are
these people got this pair of
psychologists in there it's supposed to
be shat's brother but it's actually the
dude who played dallas in alien one the
ship's tom scary yeah and his name is
also tom in the movie yeah so that's
handy yeah and he's actually good in
this movie he is actually i like him a
lot so actually tom skerritt and his
wife
end up sort of being the heroes because
his wife uh is what's her wife's name
the wife's name is julie i think it's
julie and she's psychic just you know
because
and so they've been at this university
and
studying her psychic abilities and also
eddie albert is there i guess he's like
tom garrett's mentor like he's a
parapsychologist or something i don't
know let me say something with that
having grown up in the la area during
this time
and uh have lois being part of the
[ __ ] university system and everything
the [ __ ] about that you see in these
movies about parapsychologists being in
the universities absolutely true yeah
they did yesterday absolutely all the
all the uh universities had a
parapsychology department i think only a
couple still do well all the big ones i
think had them but uh i don't think they
have many more
dude i think it's all well when i wrote
um when i wrote unseen hand i think
there were three like a major no in in
the country okay in california all the
big universities had them ucla i believe
had one and usc and uh but they they had
them
and
uh i think they were getting results
according to lois you know and
dr penner her boss who was uh you know
ran in
who was in the palomar observatory and
everything friends of carl sagan they
believed that stuff
and
i think that helped to
foster the environment
because i would i grew up believing in
that because that's
my parents and my aunt and everything
that who knew scientists and they said
it was real and i think that
faith in it is what caused
the paranormal events that mountain that
we wrote the book about and the stuff
that happens in here having
believing it allows it i believe
i just i've seen it
so
but and evidently so does the military
they had project stargate they did some
other stuff but it's and a lot of this
stuff kind of went underground
uh but yeah i believe the military and
knows about it remote viewing and stuff
um anyway sidetrack but
just saying that the parapsychology
element of this story is accurate that's
the way it was back then well i kind of
feel like a lot i mean the late 60s
early 70s were kind of a hotbed of not
only
paranormal psychic ability type movies
but also satanist movies yeah so this
kind of like it seems like it's trying
to combine this
it might have helped fuel the satanic
panic
it oh it did absolutely i mean it
started kind of started with rosemary's
baby
but after that you know it just kind of
ramped up and ramped up because after
rosemary's baby came out it was like a
big success then everybody's like ooh we
need a satan movie too yeah yeah is it
messiah billy's
if there's evidence for psy abilities
and that they're a reality then that
means bad behavior like [ __ ] happening
in
satanic rituals could
in theory
activate evil psy abilities which that
would be witchcraft
yeah that's like that's like the dark
side of the force
and uh they believe that
and uh so do i
yeah and i don't think it's as
extravagant as it's shown in the movies
had to go up there and put a picture
back up
yeah it was weird
anyway we should change subject yeah
okay
uh so yeah so you have this kind of like
parapsychology element coming into it so
it turns out like from this point tom
skerritt and his wife
are the heroes because it turns out that
he's uh chat's brother like i keep
saying i keep calling him the shot like
his character name is mark he gets mad
mark friendship yeah too i think well
[ __ ] that dude well he's not listening
to this right now he's like it is nice
he wins the space he
yeah he did
um so yeah he went to space so he didn't
give a [ __ ] what all his earthlings uh
say dude he dudes in his 90s he's
[ __ ] long-lived didn't he he is yeah
yeah
but maybe there's something to that like
uh you know self-love thing but um that
like being really in love with yourself
but yeah so
so it turns out like tom scara i guess
like his wife
has a vision about the family and about
like they're in trouble or whatever so
so tom and julie have to go to redstone
and try to save the family
now
let me see if i can parse this out
because there's some point and i think
that julie i guess they made her psychic
just so they could have like exposition
type stuff happening so you could see
like [ __ ] that happened in the past or
whatever
it turns out that corbis ernest borgnine
he is i don't know i don't i don't know
if he's not like immortal or anything
but i guess like his ancestors like he's
kind of like been possessed by the devil
like for hundreds of years or whatever
so he back in the 1600s i guess he had
this book
and it had all the names of the people
whose souls he had sold to satan or
whatever and it was all written in there
in blood even though it's clearly like a
pink marker but whatever so it's like in
there in blood
and apparently
william shatner's
uh ancestor whose name was martin feife
i think
he stole the book from corbis like back
or his wife did or something like back
in the day
and then
so he ended up getting burned at the
stake like ernest borgnine's character
like dressed like a pilgrim because they
do that too
and but then martin and his wife also
didn't they also get burned at the stake
but the thing about it is that ernest
borgnett is like yeah satan's my bro so
i'm gonna curse you like forever and i'm
just gonna like haunt your descendants
like until i get that [ __ ] book back
so he basically just wants this book
that
william shatner's family has so that's
kind of what the thing is it doesn't
really make a huge amount of difference
i don't know why he needs it um i don't
know why because that he has another
thing
that's kind of like a big
faberge egg with a tv in it yeah this is
sort of this gimmick here is pretty cool
i kind of like the way that they do it
though it's kind of like this big egg
fabric egg egg with a [ __ ] goat head
and it's got a goat head on top there's
no gold and it's got goat feet also and
then like it's got a hole in the middle
and then like they put a tv in there
like you could tell it's a tv but it
still looks really cool yeah they got a
cool kind of like round lens on it yeah
and it's like a color tv in there but
that's the soul entrapment device he's
got all the souls trapped in there
people trying ah like the phantom zone
out of [ __ ] yeah it is yeah it's kind
of like that at us at a [ __ ] superman
but i think that the faberge egg with
the souls in it
i think that thing is the devil's reign
okay i don't know why like the soul
containment device
is called the devil's reign
i don't understand what
why why is it called that i don't know
see that's what i'm saying it doesn't
make sense it doesn't make sense but
yeah so the thing about it the devil's
nuts
i mean the devil's egg yeah you think it
would why would you call the devil's egg
that would have been a cool title yeah i
don't know why rain i guess rain because
they're like well we want everybody to
melt at the end maybe and like rate you
know rain cheesy water melts like you
know like the wicked witch of the west
and wizard of oz that's what we're doing
yeah you're so bad water melts you
i'm like yeah [ __ ] stupid it's just
like the aliens from science but yeah
which i don't think they melted but yeah
but so yeah so i guess the egg is called
the devil's reign
so after like tom and julie get there
and they're like oh our family's [ __ ]
they're all eyeless and weird looking
and they figure out
that
not only that corbis is like looking for
the book but also they figure out hey
maybe if we destroy
this devil's rain egg thing
then all the people's souls will come
back i guess that's what they were
shooting for i think
so they actually do end up doing that or
he talks william shatner who is still
kind of possessed into doing it into
like breaking the egg
but then when he breaks the egg
then it makes it rain outside
and all the acolytes melt
like into horrible
another thing too is that and i kind of
made this joke
when we were watching the movie but you
can shoot at the acolytes like it'll
kill them and stuff like that you could
shoot at it but like the stuff that
comes out of the bullet holes looks like
pistachio ice cream yeah which i thought
was funny like they didn't want to show
blood for somebody they're full of
pistachio maybe that's why maybe that's
kind of why this got a pg rating even
though it shows people straight up
melting and like satanic worship and
yeah it was all pink and blue
yeah it was it was like orange and like
lime green it looked like sherbet yeah
it looked like yeah it looked like they
shot him and like two flavors of sherbet
we're coming out of the vulnerable yeah
they're just trying to get asses into
seats everybody come see it yeah yeah
and it's just kind of like i mean so
they didn't want to our rating i guess
so yeah this is how they got around to
the yeah and they did a good job doing
that because like it's still pretty
gross and goopy and everything like that
but it doesn't look bloody which is so
funny to me i guess because i think
that's kind of a thing i don't know like
how accurate this is but a lot of times
the people like well we want to make
kind of like a a gross movie but like
kind of like an american hammer horror
film in a way you know what i mean that
level of [ __ ] gore which there wasn't
much gore at all really didn't have any
boobs though
yeah i don't think i don't think there
was any other than shots hammer yeah
just
hammer will come at you with just some
gorgeous european chicks to get you
[ __ ] come in there and pay that money
and sit down in that seat and uh this
movie didn't they didn't try that angle
no they just they were just like satan
right and melting yeah and goopy people
yeah which like i said the meltdown
looks cool
go ahead yeah it's we keep saying go
ahead it looks good we keep saying a
goat head but it's actually it's not a
whole mask it's prosthetics like they
put it on his face yeah and then he's
got like big horns and like big goat
hair and stuff i think it looks cool
yeah and you can see his eyes and he can
talk through it and everything it looked
good yeah i thought it looked really
cool i thought it looks really cool
but it doesn't look real but it's not
supposed to it's all fantasy yeah that's
what i mean it's fine it's like
something a damn sinbad or something
um another thing i like about this one
is that not only do you get 10 minutes
of a bunch of satanist melting at the
end but also the satanists kind of win
yeah come back you think you think they
lost but then they they make a comeback
yeah and it's just kind of like it's
pretty [ __ ] up
so i mean i don't really understand it
doesn't matter the mythology behind it i
don't understand why i think they pulled
it out of their ass well clearly like i
said maybe i don't know maybe like the
screenwriters were just maybe like
whatever it makes it made sense to them
clearly um or they were just too lazy to
fix it
and they were just like yeah it makes
total sense just like just rolling it
makes total sense don't worry about it i
mean it sort of makes sense i get the
whole thing about you know this is a
generational curse you know they have
the fife family had the book and corbis
is trying to get the book back because
he needs it for some reason for some
ritual or whatever i don't get why the
devil's reign is an egg with the souls
in it like i get that that thing is a
thing that exists
like you know we we make the satanic
acolytes and then their soul goes in
this doohickey here but i don't know
what that has to do with rain other than
we just want to make everybody melt at
the end it was they pulled it out of
their ass yeah so it's just so just this
is one of those movies it's on to be uh
at the moment if you want to watch it
might be other places too but that's
where we watched it and it's been on
there for like forever if this is one of
those movies where
um one it kind of starts in the middle
of everything and you'll just be like
what the [ __ ] is going on who are these
people [ __ ] like that but just like sit
tight it's sort of explained um it's
just fun because
the cast is great the effects the makeup
effects are great like the it's really
the cinematography like the desert
settings and stuff like that are really
cool looking honestly i think
this has
you know with the with the guys like you
know the people with no eyes and like
all the melting and stuff it has like
some really creepy
imagery it just has that kind of like
mid 70s like creepy satanic vibe it's a
fun movie because it is just kind of
like gargoyles yeah gargoyles is similar
yeah a desert movie
it's got a satanic vibe to it but it's
mostly fun
and it does have creepy elements to it
you know
but um i i put this up there with like
maybe gargoyles
but you know what it does that tops
gargoyles yeah i think this is a bit
better it's got shot in it and it's got
the dude from alien and it's got [ __ ]
ernest borgnine just [ __ ] chewing up
the scenery dude it's his best role
he's having a great time yeah it's his
best role and like i said i think he
looks cool yeah and he looks [ __ ]
badass
and you never see earnest as a [ __ ]
villain but not usually really good i
mean he's been in [ __ ] tons of movies
maybe he played a villain in another one
that i haven't seen but yeah usually he
plays kind of like a schlubby friendly
guy yeah he doesn't look slubby he's
very [ __ ] kind of sleek looking in
his face and it's just
the way he's you just got to see it he's
using his eyebrows for evil yeah yeah as
it was as intended right
because he doesn't have this he's still
not skinny or anything you know i mean
just he looks real [ __ ] menacing
doing doing his best [ __ ] ernest
borgnine the bad guy and he'd have made
a good bad guy he did make a good bad
guy
yeah it's so yeah so it's kind of cool
like because he just gets to play like
very
friendly bob he's usually friendly bob
and yeah he but he gets to play like
real sinister in this yeah but also kind
of like hammy like but hammy sinister
but it's fun
and yeah so and all the satanic prayers
and [ __ ] yeah it's cool i like it doing
sorcerer [ __ ] yeah he does a good job
but yeah so yeah this is just like a fun
movie just have a few drinks don't think
too hard about it because it doesn't
make a lot of sense but just drink drink
yeah just drink and watch it it has like
really cool uh you know kind of visuals
to it i don't know and there's just
something about like these this these
era satanic movies that i really like
yeah you see that's heading into the era
of you know um
uh what was the amityville horror you
just said that those movies are coming
you know it's leading up to that you can
see it in the movie yeah yeah and it's
fun to see it's fun to see tom skerritt
in this like so young because this was
what like four years before alien yeah
he looks pretty same age to me but yeah
he doesn't really look no that much i
mean
his hair is a little bit longer but
that's about it he does good job in it
yeah and like i said he's kind of ends
up being the hero yeah he's kind of
playing the same role in a way he's like
dallas really was not not a big
difference
that's true he's probably playing
himself you know yeah he's like what's
all this satanic [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
let me come here and like [ __ ] fight
yeah it's like kind of like get him
honey
[Laughter]
but yeah so the devil's reign go watch
it on to be or you know if you've seen
it like talk about it in the comments
but yeah i really like this movie and
you know i like satanic movies from this
era so that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys on the
next one bye
you